The edge that should be different is the one on the left.
Let's trace through it to see why.
We know when we run this program that it should say "hello gracie."
When we're running a function, our official rule is
you take the function body--here's the function body--
"right greeting" plus "person"--and you evaluate it in that frame--
"right greeting" plus "spaces" plus "person."
We go to look up "greeting." Do we have it?
No. Let's go ask our parents.
Oh, our parents do have a greeting--it's "hola."
Look up "person"--do we have it?
Yes, it's "gracie."
With the bug, this program will mistakenly
print out "hola gracie."
That's not what we wanted. That doesn't match the semantics.
If instead I erase this edge and draw it correctly,
having this function point back to the environment
in which it was defined, now when I try to write
"greeting" plus "person," do I have "greeting?"
No. How about my parent?
Oh, my parent does, and it's "hello."
How about "person," "gracie?"
We'll write out "hello gracie."
So with the bug we get "hola gracie."
Without the bug we get, correctly, "hello gracie."